Follow Lane,
focus on facebook,
twitter,
and instagram.
Hello everyone.
Welcome to the Lange Focus Channel and
my name is Paul and despite what half
the people in the comments say,
English is my native language,
why doesn't he show his birth
certificate and you know what?
I wish he would.
He should show his birth certificate.
The other thing,
why doesn't he show his birth
certificate?
Today's topic is 10 common mistakes that
native English speakers make.
When most of us study a foreign
language,
we try to avoid mistakes and speak
accurately.
Some of us are even scared to make
mistakes,
but you know what?
Even native speakers make mistakes and
that includes speakers of my native
language.
English.
When I say mistakes,
I'm not talking about dialectal
variation.
English has various dialects that differ
from the standard language,
and I'm not talking about those
differences.
I'm talking about native speakers of
dialects that are very close to standard
English,
but who make mistakes?
What kind of mistakes?
Well,
here are 10 of them.
Number 10,
unclear subject number.
For example,
every one of those people need to buy a
ticket.
The correct sentence would be every one
of those people needs to buy a ticket
because the plural word people is right
next to the verb.
Some people might mistake it for the
subject,
but the subject of the sentence is
actually every one of the people is
extra information about that subject.
Everyone is singular.
Number nine,
confusing homophones.
When writing homophones are words that
sound the same as other words that have
a different meaning and usually have a
different spelling.
One common example is the confusion of
effect and effect.
This confusion arises because the first
vowel of each word is often reduced and
sounds like a Schwab and this makes them
sound like when someone's writing the
word,
they may be hearing the sound of the
word in their head and they might choose
the wrong spelling to go with that
sound.
Another example of this is they're there
and they're there and they're sound the
same,
but they are.
Sounds a little different,
but in its reduced form basically sounds
the same,
but people often choose the wrong one.
When writing.
Another example is the confusion of
your,
the possessive Pronoun with your.
The contraction of you are.
Another example is writing of instead of
Apostrophe v,
the contracted form of,
for example,
someone might write,
I would have gone to the party if I'd
had time,
but it should be would've with
Apostrophe v.
They sound the same and casual
pronunciation,
so that's why they get confused.
Number eight,
confusion of adjectives and adverbs.
For example,
he's saying really good,
good as an adjective,
but we need an adverb to modify the verb
sang so the correct sentences.
He sang really well.
This mistake is the mistake that kids
often make before they've had English
grammar drilled into them and it's also
the kind of mistake that less educated
people might make.
Even educated people might make this
mistake,
but they'd probably notice it right away
and maybe correct themselves.
Another related cases that people
sometimes use an adverb when they
actually need an adjective.
So take this case for example.
I feel very badly about that.
The sentence is wrong.
It should be.
I feel very bad about that,
but why is it wrong?
I thought adverbs modify verb,
well,
adverbs,
modify action verbs,
but feel is a state of verb.
It just describes the way something is.
The state that it's in.
It doesn't describe an actual state of
verbs are followed by adjectives,
not advert.
Inevitably,
someone will ask,
what about the sentence?
I feel.
Well,
isn't that correct?
Yes,
that's a correct sentence,
but well is not an adverb in that
sentence.
It's actually an adjective meaning
healthy.
It's not the adverb equivalent of the
adjective.
Good.
Number seven,
double negatives.
Most educated adults won't make this
mistake and if they do,
it's probably kind of an intentional
casual style of speaking.
You know,
trying to sound all bad ass.
A double negative is like this.
I don't have no money,
man.
The correct sentence would be I don't
have any money,
man.
Another example I didn't talk to nobody
correct sentence would be I didn't talk
to anybody so that one could be a
mistake or it could be people
intentionally trying to copy the
features of a dialect that's cool and
popular.
Number six,
not using the subjunctive mood.
Subjunctive mood as a form of the verb.
That's used for something not factual
like possibility or desire or a
necessity in English.
The subjunctive has a unique form in the
third person present tense and the verb
to be has a unique forum in the third
person past tense.
Some people just don't use it at all or
they're confused about when to use it.
For example,
it's important that he goes to the
hospital that's actually wrong.
The correct sentence would be,
it's important that he go to the
hospital.
We need the subjunctive mood here to
show necessity.
Another example,
if I was rich,
the correct version would be if I were
rich here,
we need the subjunctive because it's
showing possibility.
Number five,
confusion of is and our this confusion
usually happens with there is and there
are or here is and here are.
For example,
here's three cookies for you.
The correct sentence would be,
here are three cookies for you.
Another example,
there's around seven people at the
party.
The correct sentence would be there are
around seven people at the party,
but so many people,
even educated speakers use both of these
forms so much that I'm not even sure
that they're considered mistakes
anymore.
Number for confusion,
that the verbs lie and lay.
Most native English speakers know that
there's a difference between these
words,
but they're kind of confused about what
the difference is or they know what the
difference is,
but they use them indirectly anyway.
Lie as an intransitive verb,
meaning it takes no direct object.
For example,
let's lie on the bed.
Oh boy.
I can imagine the comments already lay
as a transitive verb,
meaning it takes a direct object.
For example,
let's lay the laundry on the bed,
but lots of people say,
let's lay on the bed and that's wrong.
People also mistake the past tense form
and the past participle of life.
I often hear people say live like he
lied on the floor or laid like he laid
on the floor,
but really the past tense of lie is lay.
In the past.
Participle is glade.
The past tense of les is late in the
past participle.
There's also laid number three,
confusion of the words,
fewer and less,
fewer as used for countdowns and less is
used for non count mountains,
but people often use less for nouns.
For example,
I eat less cookies than I used to.
Cookies are accountable,
so the correct sentence is I eat fewer
cookies.
Then I used to.
That kind of mistake is very widespread
number too confusing.
The past tense form and the past
participle form of irregular verbs.
For example,
the group to go has the past tense form
went in the past participle gone,
but lots of people say things like,
I should have went to the party,
but the correct sentence is I should've
gone to the party.
Another example,
the verb to drink the past tense form is
drank in the past.
Participle is drunk.
Some people say things like,
he's already drank two beers and it's
only 4:00
PM,
but it should be.
He's already drunk.
Two Beers,
number one,
misuse of the word.
Literally.
The real original meaning of this word
is that something in reality is exactly
as spoken without metaphor or
exaggeration.
For example,
if you say she literally has thousands
of pairs of shoes,
that means if you count all of her pairs
of shoes,
there will be thousands of them.
Not Hundreds,
not dozens,
but really thousands,
but these days people often use the word
literally just to put emphasis on
something that's not actually literally,
for example,
that guy has literally a monster.
Oh,
really?
That sentence means that he looks like
this.
He's not a human.
He's a real monster,
but that's not what they meant.
They just meant that he's a bad person.
This kind of mistake literally makes me
scream,
what are you waiting for me to scream?
I don't actually scream.
I didn't mean that.
Literally.
I think that basically all native
speakers make some mistakes in writing
and in speaking,
if we judge by strict grammatical
standards,
sometimes it's because they're just
thinking on their feet and maybe their
ideas aren't completely organized,
so things come out a little bit unclear
and sometimes it might be a habitual
mistake.
They repeat the same mistake over and
over,
but the issue is not black and white.
Obviously standard languages need rules
so that there's not total chaos,
but at the same time languages are
always evolving and sometimes a mistake
may be a new innovation in the language
that just doesn't match the rules of
grammar yet because the rules of grammar
would decided in the past.
So the question of the day for native
English speakers,
what do you think of the kind of
mistakes that I described in the video?
Do you think that they're a danger to
the English language or do you see them
as mere innovations or does it depend on
the case and the question of the day for
native speakers of other languages,
do you notice these kinds of mistakes in
your own native language?
What do you think of them?
Leave your comments down below.
Be sure to follow lane,
focus on facebook,
twitter,
and Instagram,
and once again,
I'd like to say thanks to all of my
patrion supporters,
especially the ones right here on the
screen for there,
especially generous pledges.
Thank you for watching and have a nice
evening.
It's like day.